last night i received my first ever
youtube strike and it was for
violent and graphic content
i can't show you the clip in question
because obviously if i did they would
just take it down and give me another
strike but i can summarize it for you
imagine spongebob mickey mouse
scrat from ice age and some purple bunny
that i'm not familiar with
all ganging up on some unsuspecting
russian guy
and beating him up in the middle of the
road it's horrifying it's terrifying
which is why it was in my try not to
laugh
challenge video specifically try not to
laugh number two
if you go search for that video it is no
longer there i am very sorry
this uh heinous video which was clearly
a danger
to the unsuspecting population of
youtube
has finally been taken down after four
ungodly years of exposure on youtube it
is finally
gone and the people can feel justice
again i mean anyone who watches this
clip would understand that it is
not violent or shocking content
and anyone can make that call for
themselves
because you can still watch this video
because it's still up on youtube
if you search on youtube for like mickey
mouse road rage or spongebob road rage
or mickey mouse spongebob road rage
incident
russia caught on camera you will find
the video and you'll know exactly what
we're talking about and you can see for
yourself how this video
is not in any way actually
violence it's a joke but not according
to the manual review system
who's making these calls we don't know
who's giving these answers
youtube doesn't know who's talking to
youtube and youtube that youtube has to
fight youtube against or youtube has to
check youtube with
who knows now i don't really care about
the video itself getting taken down
i mean i do but you know i don't what i
do
care about is youtube's uneven
application of their own rules and i'm
usually the first person to give them
the benefit of the doubt when they make
like a controversial decision
or they you know make a mistake i
usually try to understand that there are
people
behind the company it's it's not just
one big start
it's a bunch of people all trying to do
what is best for the platform and the
creators but in
this case it is actually the people
behind the scenes
that are making the mistake for me this
all started last night when i was made
aware of a tweet
by mr moist himself saying
that he had gotten a community strike
and he said to team youtube that it was
unfair which it was
youtube replied that they were looking
into it and to no one's surprise they
upheld their decision
doubling down on the mistake this
especially wasn't a surprise to
the moist man himself because he made a
video that he recorded before they even
responded
calling that they would not reverse the
decision in an act of desperation i did
what any sad boy scout would do
i tweeted it youtube i gave it a whirl
to see what that would do
and they responded saying they look into
it and thanks for my patience and you
know what
i don't expect the answer to change in
fact i'm so confident it won't that i've
already made this before they give me
their final answer
and i imagine by the time i upload this
they will have already said on twitter
publicly
that the video violates their policy and
that i should review their terms of
service or something similar to that
effect
that video is linked in the description
if you want to check it out i suggest
you do because it gives a lot more
context
as to why this is all stupid in the
first place but
where i get involved is when he made a
follow-up tweet that had a screenshot
from one of my videos the try not to
laugh video
with the same clip that he got a strike
for
and he asked why didn't i get a strike
when is that one coming
and a lot of people were like oh no he's
snitching on mark and that's literally
not the case here that's not what it's
about i've got nothing but respect
for the good mythical moist but it when
it came down to it
i'm always ready to throw down when it
comes to these issues
so i quote tweeted him tagging team
youtube and saying fair is fair
when am i gonna get a strike and to my
actual surprise
i did get one which was interesting
interesting choice on their part now
because it's my first strike i get off
with a warning
which means that i can still upload and
stuff but the problem is
there's clearly an issue with improper
application
or at least uneven application of
youtube's community guidelines
and moreover there's a communication
issue at the heart of it all
now i want to be very clear i'm not
against the rules themselves
those rules are there for a reason and
there is content that falls within those
rules that should
be taken down which is why they have
manual review in the first place but
that also
is its own issue and to better
understand that issue i should put in
perspective just how
big youtube actually is some of you may
already know this but um
it's it's something like as of may of
2019 youtube gets approximately
500 hours of video uploaded
every single minute
if you thought i was gonna say hour or
day you were dead wrong
minute that turns into 30 000
hours of content per hour
720 000 hours per day
which is 82 years
of content every day and in that content
is obviously going to be some pretty
messed up [ __ ]
which is why youtube has this community
guidelines in the first place
and which is why we are all agreeing
that that [ __ ] should be taken down
anything that actually falls within the
rules should be
but it's not uh critical explains this
more in another video that i will link
in the description where he talks about
literal animal abusers that have videos
that are still up or their channels are
still
up and we can all agree that those types
of videos or anything equally horrendous
should be taken down immediately no
one's arguing that
but again with the number problem if
youtube were to have people
manually checking every single video
every single day assuming like eight
hours a day
with no breaks in between and they only
have to watch the video once to make the
right call
which is probably not the case but we're
assuming
they would need 90 000 people
every single day working seven days a
week 365 days a year
and i highly doubt that they have 90 000
people working around the clock
it seems awfully unrealistic but you
know what they do have
they have tens of millions of people
watching
every single video on youtube multiple
times they have you all of you all the
millions of people that watch youtube
around the world around the clock
constantly are there and that's why they
have the self-moderation system that's
why they have reporting that's why they
have
all the different categories to report
under and when they get reports
enough of them on videos then they
manually re review them
i i think that's how it works but what
is the point of having a self-moderating
community
if they just don't
listen we are telling you that not only
this video
is not violent or graphic content and it
is clearly not and everyone
agrees that it's not but we are also
pointing out videos that
do go against the community guidelines
that are not being taken down
even years later they're not being taken
down
by the way the clip that i used is from
the incredibly talented james
lee who's also linked in the description
just wonderful stuff you should check
them out but
they need to trust their creators and
community
more uh you know what's funny about this
is if they really
had a problem with this clip let's say
for example this clip
was actually bad which is not but let's
just say for example you know what they
could have done to handle it
they could have reached out they could
have just
talked to us they could have asked us to
take it down i'd like to think that we
have a good reputation you know if a
channel is actually in
good standing with no strikes why can't
they
ask us to do it for them why not ask
us to self-moderate i i don't know if
you know this but youtube actually has a
feature where you can go into any video
that you've already uploaded even if
it's public
and you can go out and you can trim out
sections of video any time
and you'll save it and then like within
a few hours it'll reprocess it and
everyone will
never see that part again and many
people won't even know that it was gone
so if you have someone in good standing
why not ask them to cut out the things
that are a problem if the whole video is
not the issue
and it's only a small clip of them why
not talk to the creators
and if they don't do it or if they don't
make a good enough case for an appeal
then use your own tools that you have
and do it for them and then give them a
strike
do it then you know what i mean be like
all right you got to take care of this
or it's a problem or we're going to give
you a strike and i can be like
look it's not i'll make my case here it
is here's my case and if i'm actually
having communication with someone and
someone comes back to me it's like look
i get it
i get it but we can't take the risk in
some circles
maybe someone might assume that it is
and they might get hurt or offended by
it and i'm like
all right fine fine i'll do it you know
but at least the whole video isn't down
i'll just trim out that part and they're
like okay that's good
thank you that we we reached a middle
ground
doesn't that sound great doesn't that
sound wonderful communication
talking yeah and i get it you know
retroactive application of rules
has to happen rules change and you know
videos are up on youtube for years and
years
and sometimes you know the community
guidelines might change and you need to
apply them on videos that were in the
past that are not okay anymore
but if that is the case give people time
to react
give people time to adjust give people
time to make
the changes that need to be changed
instead of just
making it for them you know giving me a
strike
in what is basically retaliation for me
reporting myself
is just petty that's all it is it's
petty
who made that call who made that call
after i tweeted
at team youtube hey fair is fair instead
of
tweeting back at me like look you know
you're right
but we stand by this and we have to
stick by it
if you could delete it that'd be great
and then you know i i would say no i'm
not going to delete it and then they
would do it anyway but at least there
was a talk about it
at least there was communication about
at least it seemed like there was
another human that cared and i want to
be very clear i want to be very very
very clear
there are people at youtube that do
genuinely care and my contact
meg has always been a champion for me i
actually have a contact at youtube my
channel is big enough that they have
deemed me worthy to have a person that
talks to me but meg still has to fight
and the fact that she or anyone else at
youtube has to fight
for me shows that there's a problem
inside youtube
who are they fighting who's butting up
against who
if the rules are even why does there
need to be a fight in the first place
that's because there's gray area and
that's where
the community needs to be trusted it all
boils down to
the only problem that youtube has ever
really had which is
communication and transparency
i don't know why they make the decisions
that they do sometimes and half the time
i don't even think they do so what i'd
like from youtube
and we will need an answer to this is
number one
removal of the strikes and reinstatement
of the video because
obviously this is not correct
application of the guidelines it just
flat out isn't
everyone can see that number two action
against the videos that are being called
out like critical has made many examples
of videos that should be taken down
or channels that are still up take
action against them
and number three communication about how
this can be avoided in the future
maybe take some of my suggestions to
heart maybe trust your community a
little more
these are not big asks well the one is a
mistake the two
is negligence and three is just trust
it's gotta happen you know i think
that's all that people really want
is some trust you know i think creators
just want to feel like they're
a part of this youtube thing and not
just another cog
in the advertising machine anyway uh if
you guys want to check out all the
videos that i've talked about they're
linked in the description uh the hashtag
startedbycritical is hashtag
answer us youtube so you can tweet at
them with that
anyway that's all i gotta say i'll be
waiting